de nos jours avec les technologies
modernes il est tentant de croire que
les machines finiront par savoirs et
savoir faire tout ce que l'humain c'est
et sait faire on l'a vu dans l'épisode
précédent
les machines ne surpasse dans de plus en
plus de domaines et pourtant la plupart
d'entre nous persistons à penser que
l'intelligence humaine est une
spécificité humaine et pour justifier
nos propos on a tendance à ressortir
plus ou moins toujours les mêmes
arguments
donc pour aujourd'hui je vous propose
d'étudier cinq arguments classiques qui
cherche à prouver la place privilégiée
de l'intelligence humaine dans l'univers
arguments 1
les machines n'ont jamais de conscience
j'ai une confiance dans le sens où j'ai
une expérience subjective de ce que je
vis et c'est dur d'imaginer qu'une
machine pourra un jour posséder une
telle conscience
olala y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire
sur le sujet tivo qu'est ce que tu fais
là bas tu parles de philosophie donc
j'arrive génial donc dis moi quel est le
problème avec l'argument de la
conscience d'abord faudrait distinguer
si on parle de conscience phénoménal ou
de conscience d'accès à 8 ans apparaît
dans une de ces vidéos
et si j'ai bien suivi la conscience
phénoménal c'est l'expérience subjective
de ce que je vis et de sentir la douleur
quand je me pince la joue oui et le
problème avec la conscience phénoménal
c'est que par définition il semble
qu'elle ne puisse pas être étudiée
objectivement mais seulement
subjectivement les seuls douleur les
seules expériences consciente que je
puisse connaître ce sont les miennes
pourtant tu pourrais imaginer mes
expériences consciente non si je me
cogne avec une raquette
tu dois pouvoir imaginer ma douleur tout
ce que je peux faire c'est imaginer ce
que je ressentirai à ta place
autrement dit je ne fais qu imaginer ma
douleur dans ta situation mais c'est
peut-être correct on peut supposer que
nos consciences phénoménal sont
similaires en effet mais ce n'est qu'un
postulat absolument invérifiable ce
postulat semble plutôt légitime dans la
mesure où on est proche biologiquement
et on peut supposer que c'est notre
biologie qui produit notre conscience
mais ça ne doit pas nous faire oublier
que en réalité je n'ai pas plus accès à
ta conscience phénoménal car la
conscience phénoménal d'une
chauve-souris ou
deux monstres verts ou d'une machine
donc si je comprends bien
l'argument les machines n'auront jamais
de conscience phénoménal c'est pas très
pertinent puisque je pourrais tout aussi
dire que toi tu n'as pas de conscience
phénoménal en effet je m'avoue bien
incapable de te le prouver et donc il
n'ya pas lieu d'en attendre davantage
des machines bien sûr qu'elles ne
pourront pas plus que moi te prouver
qu'elles ont une conscience phénoménal
ok mais qu'en est il de l'autre sens de
la conscience la conscience taxe m la
notion de conscience d'accès et moins
mystérieuse pour savoir si le contenu
d'une perception par exemple est
conscient au sens de la conscience
d'accès il suffit que le sujet soit
capable de rapporter ce contenu en le
décrivant par exemple c'est aussi simple
que ça et quand on étudie la commission
on se rend compte que beaucoup beaucoup
de contenu mentaux bien qu'étant traité
dans le cerveau passe sous le radar de
la conscience d'accès en effet
l'intelligence humaine analyse toutes
les données sensorielles en temps réel
c'est à dire des gigaoctets de données
par seconde et beaucoup beaucoup de ces
données doivent être filtrés et
immédiatement supprimées pour ne pas
pourrir nos disques durs de données
massives sans intérêt c'est une façon de
décrire ce qui se passe en effet la
conscience d'accès en grosse d'une
capacité à surveiller sélectionné mettre
en commun est utilisé de façon contrôler
les contenus manteau issus des
différents systèmes qui tourne dans
notre cerveau est en cela c'est une
fonction cognitive une fonction
cognitive qui se laisse étudié
objectivement et qu'il serait tout à
fait envisageable d'implémenter dans une
machine ça n'a rien d'inimaginable en
fait la conscience d'accès semble même
indispensable à l'intelligence tout
comme l'inconscience d'accès c'est à
dire le traitement d'informations
rapidement rendu inaccessible semble
indispensable à l'intelligence humaine
arguments 2 les machines n'auront jamais
de volonté propre programme et c'est
donner des instructions
or des machines doivent être programmées
du coup les machines ne peuvent que
suivre des instructions mais tu bien sûr
toi même de ne pas suivre les
instructions d'un programme dont tu
ignorais tout si j'agis de telle ou
telle façon dentelle et telles
circonstances on pourrait croire que
c'est parce que mon système nerveux
était programmée de telle sorte que
placés dans ces circonstances là ils
produisent ce comportement alors
qu'imaginer le conte
r ça revient à postuler que nous seuls
disposons d'une sorte de liberté magique
qui nous permettrait de ne pas être
soumis aux mêmes lois que le reste de
l'univers ok mais je n'ai pas vraiment
l'impression de suivre un programme moi
quand tu fermes 1,9 tu n'as pas
l'impression qu'il y a une tache aveugle
milieu de ton champ visuel et pourtant
c'est le cas mais tu est programmé pour
corriger automatiquement ce défaut de
perception ah ouais je vois mais les
instructions ce programme tu n'y a pas
accès et tu ne peux pas non plus le
contrôler ça relève de l'inconscience et
c'est tout sauf un défaut quand ma
vessie sur le point de déborder
je suis bien content d'avoir un
programme qui me le signalent et me dit
d'aller la vider d'autre part si tu as
l'impression de ne pas suivre un
programme c'est peut-être aussi parce
que personne n'a écrit les instructions
tu suis nous n'avons pas été programmé
intentionnellement notre programme c'est
écrit au fil de l'évolution et il est
programmé pour se modifier lui-même au
fil du temps si je suis programmé à
sentir l'envi de vider ma vessie quand
celle-ci se remplit ce n'est pas parce
qu'un programmeur la encodées dans mon
programme c'est parce que la sélection
naturelle a sélectionné les individus
dont les programmes posséder cette
instruction
bref nous n'avons pas le même rapport
avec la programmation des machines parce
que au départ c'est nous qui les
programmes ont intentionnellement et
nous sommes conscients des programmes
qu'elles suivent alors en effet pendant
longtemps c'était comme ça que les
ordinateurs étaient programmés mais avec
l'avènement du machine learning et des
algorithmes génétiques qui simule une
évolution darwinienne les machines
d'aujourd'hui sont de moins en moins le
produit des intentions consciente des
programmeurs et cie ont implémenté une
méta commission dans une machine pour
simuler une conscience d'accès il est
probable que celle-ci n'aurait pas accès
à toute sa commission et donc pourrait
se sentir aussi peut programmer que nous
pire encore certains programmes
autogénérés comme le dip learning sont
aujourd'hui si complexe que leur contenu
échappent très largement à leurs
développeurs
plus troublant encore de nos jours on
peut se demander si c'est vraiment nous
qui disons machine que faire ou si ce ne
sont pas déjà les machines qui nous
disent que faire notamment via les
systèmes de recommandations comme
youtube ou netflix arguments 3 les
machines ne font pas d'erreurs
errare humanum est pas forcément est
rare et etiam makina est une question de
ton attend au hockey excusez moi
monsieur et cetera et cetera et cetera
c'est vrai que je suis inexcusable si
nous ne faisons que suivre des
programmes l'erreur peut tout bêtement
venir des programmes que nous suivons je
commets une erreur lorsque je vise un
objectif mais la décision que je prends
tenta plutôt m'éloigner de la
réalisation de cet objectif par exemple
si je joue au gaumont but est d'avoir un
maximum de territoires s'ils jouent un
coût faible un coût qui me fait perdre
du territoire eh bien je commets une
erreur et on peut transposer ça pour des
machines un programme de jeu de go a
finalement le même objectif que moi
gagner la partie en ayant plus de
territoire que son adversaire et il va
chercher à évaluer les différents coups
possibles en vue d'atteindre cet
objectif
certes aujourd'hui on peut avoir
l'impression khalfa go qui a battu les
meilleurs joueurs humains du monde ne
commet pas d'erreurs mais avant cela les
programmes de go était assez nul et il
joue et souvent des coûts faibles et
pourtant ils avaient le même objectif de
gagner la partie
ce qui revient à dire qu'il commettait
des erreurs finalement on pourra
objecter que ce n'était pas des erreurs
puisqu'il ne faisait que suivre des
instructions mais dans ce cas en quoi
fais moins d erreurs lorsque je joue un
mauvais coup au go puisque de même on
pourrait dire que c'est le coût que mon
programme cérébrale de jeu de go me
déterminé à jouer dans ces circonstances
bref il est difficile de donner un sens
à l'idée d' erreur qui ne s'applique
qu'aux êtres humains même pour un cas
aussi simple que une erreur au jeu de go
alors parfois on parle d'erreur quand on
est censé suivre un programme et qu'on
échoue à se faire et en pratique ça ça
arrive aussi aux machines
et oui les machines sont des objets
physiques et du coup il peut avoir des
perturbations physiques des signaux par
exemple qui vont d'un microprocesseur à
l'autre en fait il y a même tout un
champ de recherche en informatique qui
s'appelle la tolérance aux fautes et qui
devient de plus en plus important au fur
et à mesure que nos systèmes
informatiques deviennent de plus en plus
complexes et aussi de plus en plus
distribuer à travers le monde ce qui
augmente le risque de perturbation des
signaux arguments 4 les machines manque
de créativité
c'est une idée assez répandue pour les
machines auront achevé de prendre tous
les vulgaires jobs mécanique nous
brillant êtres humains pourront enfin
nous consacrer pleinement aux travaux
créatifs ainsi selon etienne klein
albert einstein aura écrit aucune
méthode inductive ne peut conduire aux
concepts fondamentaux de la physique
l'incapacité à le comprendre et la plus
grave erreur philosophique de nombreux
penseurs du 19e siècle
on a tendance à penser que des actes
créatives comme la peinture la musique
ou la poésie
sont ceux qui font la spécificité de
l'humain sauf que des algorithmes nous
sommes tout à fait capables de produire
des oeuvres qu'on pourrait tout à fait
jugé intéressante vu qu'on ignore
quelles ont été créées par des
algorithmes
il suffit de faire un tour sur 10
partout sur 18 generator pour s'en
convaincre
je vous renvoie vers les nombreux autres
exemples dont on a parlé dans l'épisode
a en fait générer des nouveaux fichiers
jpg mp3 ou txt pour une machine c'est
super facile
et en plus ça l'est beaucoup plus
productif que nous en fait ce qu'il
manque aujourd'hui c'est pas tant la
créativité qu'une fonction d'évaluations
esthétique qui lui permettrait de
sélectionner les oeuvres intéressantes
dans son immense production et une
capacité à produire un discours
expliquant son oeuvre à se prendre pour
un artiste pour ainsi dire oui parce que
au final la créativité ce n'est qu'une
façon de sélectionner un objet parmi un
ensemble très très très grand et dès
aujourd'hui il existe bel et bien des
façons bien qu'un précise de juge est
approximativement de la qualité est une
oeuvre artistique et ce qui est vrai des
arts est vrai des maths et de la
physique aussi d'ailleurs et machines
crée déjà tout plein de nouvelles maths
et même de nouvelles preuves
mathématiques notamment via le logiciel
coque et je vous renvoie vers les
pilotes sur l'infini pour en savoir plus
argument 5 l'incomplétude de gödel enfin
un dernier argument récurrent celui
avancé par le mathématicien rogers
penrose cet argument repose sur le
théorème d'incomplétude eu de gödel et
le fait que nous autres humains avons
démontré l'existence de théorèmes vrai
mais qui n'ont pas de preuve
or un ordinateur purement logique ne
sera pas démontrée la vérité de ce
théorème du coup nous serons toujours
quelque chose qu'une machine purement
logique ne saura jamais le problème avec
ce raisonnement c'est qu'il repose sur
un contresens ou en tout cas une
confusion sur la notion de démontre
habilité en particulier la démontre
habilité d'un théorème n'est pas une
notion absolue elle dépend toujours de
l'ensemble des axiomes et des règles
d'inférence que l'on accepte dans notre
théorie mathématique et en gros tout
théorème indémontrable dans une théorie
le sera dans une autre théorie
en fait ce qu'a montré que goodell en
gros c'est que pour toutes ensemble
d'actions et de règles d'inférence qui
permettent de construire au moins
l'arithmétique
on peut construire une formule j'ai tel
qu'on ne peut démontrer ni gêne ni sa
négation à partir de cet ensemble
d'actions et de règles d'inférence voilà
tous
sexy mais c'est aussi plus exact donc si
on programme une ia à faire de
l'arithmétique se dire en gros on l'a
programme à déduire de façon mécanique
des théorèmes à partir des actions de
l'arithmétique
cette machine en effet ne pourra jamais
prouver le théorème d'incomplétude de
gödel pour la simple raison que cette
machine ne peut prouver que des
théorèmes d'arithmétique
or le théorème d'incomplétude de gödel
n'est pas un théorème d'arithmétique
mais un théorème sur l'arithmétique et
ce théorème n'est pas démontrée dans
l'arithmétique mais dans la théorie qui
étudie la théorie arithmétique ce qu'on
appelle du coup une méta théorie et si
vous voulez formalisé complètement la
démonstration de google
il faudrait action baptisée cette méta
théorie dans une méta mais ta théorie et
cetera et cetera
pour plus de détails sur tout ça je vous
renvoie vers les épisodes 17 et 18 de la
série sur un fini si l'on restreint les
ja dans le domaine mathématiques et être
des machines à produire des théorèmes à
partir d'un ensemble d'actions medreg
d'inférence l'objection serait
pertinente mais on voit mal ce qui
empêcherait de programmer une ia
étudiants l'âme et arithmétique ou de
façon plus générale les relations entre
langage et métalangage bref quand on
étudie la logique on les tue dit souvent
depuis l'extérieur et c'est pour ça
qu'on arrive à conclure des choses comme
ce que goodell a conclu sauf qu'une
machine peut aussi très bien faire ça
alors il reste une objection plus
subtile qui s'appuie sur le théorème
d'indécis d'habilité de turing ce
théorème dit qu'il existe des problèmes
qu aucune machine ne saura résoudre
comme le problème de la rai dont parle
patience alors oui une machine ne sera
pas résoudre ce problème mais il est
alors bien présomptueux de penser qu'un
humain y arrivera et que la réponse de
l'humain sera plus fiable que celle
d'une machine
bref les arguments contre les caps
des machines à atteindre et à dépasser
l'intelligence humaine sont en fait loin
d'être solide
alors je comprends que cette conclusion
ne vous plaisent pas puisqu'elle remet
en cause notre place privilégiée dans le
cosmos et la morale des hooligans nous
pousse à défendre les nôtres notre
humano centrisme a du mal à admettre que
l'intelligence humaine ne soit peut-être
pas si spécial que ça alors que force
est de reconnaître que quand il s'agit
d'effectuer de longues des visions les
machines sont déjà bien plus
intelligente du moins bien plus capable
que nous autres humains notre humano
centrisme tend aussi à nous faire croire
que le niveau humain d'intelligence
représente une sorte de borne que
l'intelligence artificielle peut tenter
d'approcher certes mais qu'elle ne
dépassera pas vraiment sauf que ça n'est
très probablement pas le cas
le fameux match d'échecs 10 blu contre
kasparov dans les années 90 a pu donner
cette vision des choses d'un jeu quasi
égal entre l'intelligence humaine et
l'intelligence artificielle mais cette
situation est assez exceptionnel et
surtout de courte durée quelques années
plus tard les i had échec était déjà
super intelligente
pareil pour le go aujourd'hui alpha go
qui avait fait la une des journaux en
2016 est devenu un joueur de go moyen
voire mauvais quand on compare à
d'autres intelligences artificielles
comme alpha 2 0 bref si on arrive à
produire une ia général il est difficile
de croire qu'elle s'élèvera juste au
niveau de l'intelligence humaine
le joual atteindra sera probablement la
veille du jour où elle le dépassera
d'aussi loin qu'elle fagots 0 dépasse
tous les joueurs humains aux jeux de
cour et c'est ce qui rend cette
entreprise si vertigineuse
d'où notamment la crainte vis-à-vis
d'une possible super intelligence
néanmoins même si on accepte le fait que
l'intelligence n'est pas une spécificité
humaine
il n'en reste pas moins qu'aujourd'hui
en tout cas produire une intelligence
humaine dans une machine ça reste bien
difficile et ça on en reparle la semaine
prochaine la nymphe en a parlé des
humains contre les machines et on a vu
que les machines et sont en train de
nous surpasser dans de plus en plus de
domaines et j'avais dit notamment que
les machines sont déjà capables de faire
beaucoup plus d'opérations par seconde
par exemple
cerveau humain et frais que fait la
remarque qu'en fait notre cerveau est
capable de faire beaucoup d'opérations
inconsciente à chaque instant les
capacités inconsciente du cerveau humain
c'est vraiment un truc en fait
incroyable qui dépasse très largement ce
qu'on sait faire aujourd'hui avec des
machines mais le multi tasking en
particulier je pense que c'est un truc
les ordinateurs font beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mieux que nous un canton à
notre téléphone notre ordinateur il ya
tellement de calcul qui se passe
derrière en tag gorn sans qu'on sache
vraiment ce qui se passe et je parle
même pas des datacenter de google qui
traitent des milliards et des milliards
d'opérations à chaque seconde
donc c'est vraiment pas comparable je
pense qu'au niveau du multi tasking ya
vraiment pas photo les machines sont
beaucoup beaucoup plus performante que
le cerveau humain patrick michaud fait
la remarque que certes les machines font
des trucs mieux que nous mais elle
consomme aussi plus d'énergie notamment
il donne l'exemple d'alpha go qui nous
sommes beaucoup plus d'énergie que le
cerveau humain ça c'est vrai mais c'est
un petit peu trompeurs comme exemple
puisque alpha gosses un peu on a mis
toute notre puissance de calcul pour
qu'il soit vraiment très très fort
plupart des tâches effectuées par les
machines
en fait sans doute beaucoup plus
efficace que si elle était faite par le
cerveau humain
je pense notamment à tout ce qui est
gestion de travail administratif ou
effectuer des longs calculs comptables
par exemple des longues auditions massa
les machines c'est juste quelques vite
d'opérations donc ça va très très vite
alors qu'un humain qui ferait ça va
affronter toutes ses heures de travail
aussi toute la nourriture qu'ils mangent
pour mater notamment son cerveau
activées aussi tout son corps à ce jeu
là je pense que les machines sont en
fait bien plus efficace que l'humain en
fait comme le fait remarquer aurait en
32 27
je pense que ce dont les machines nous
font vraiment prendre conscience avec
elles pointent en fait on n'est vraiment
pas si exceptionnel que dans beaucoup de
tâches que l'on fait ben commet beaucoup
d'erreurs n'est pas très rapide et
finalement beaucoup de jobs humains sont
loin d'être des truc exceptionnel
la dernière fois que j'avais donné un
exemple de google qui était capable
d'améliorer la résolution d'image très
pixélisé et jason brown ce qui nous fait
la remarque qu'en fait le travail de
google qui dresse de mars 2010 est
pourtant est en fait déjà obsolète est
devenu obsolète dès mai 2010 est
puisqu'en mai 2010 est un truc basé sur
des networks dégâts atteint des
compétences absolument incroyable dans
cette faculté à affiner la résolution
des images pourtant très pixélisé et je
pense surtout que ça montre à quel point
ça va incroyablement vite dans ce
domaine il ya énormément d'innovation de
nouveaux résultats qui apparaissent
vraiment tous les mois c'est vraiment un
domaine complètement fou et quand on se
rend compte de vitesse du progrès en
intelligent certifier ces mois ci qui
est beaucoup plus grand que il ya un an
pendant un mois et ben commence à se
dire que peut-être que dans un an ça va
continuer avec serré à exponentiellement
et du coup c'est très très très
difficile de prévoir l'état de l'ia dans
un angle de guerre forcerie encore plus
dans 5 ou 10 ans enfin romain thibault
et thibault ne veut ne sont pas d'accord
avec mon osef sur la sémantique entre
iya et machine learning est il une bonne
raison à cela c'est que en fait
historiquement l'intelligence
artificielle incluait des trucs qui
était pas du learning qui n'était pas de
l'apprentissage des machines c'était
plus des algorithmes mais en tout cas il
y avait un sous domaine de
l'informatique et qui a été
l'intelligence artificielle qui
développé ses propres algorithmes
sauf que aujourd'hui ces techniques
elles sont pas du tout à la pointe de ce
qui se fait en intelligence artificielle
et puis surtout à l'histoire je vous
envie de dire aux africains un moment il
y à une époque on pensait que pays était
un nombre rationnelle je veux dire
l'état des connaissances évoluent et si
on veut vraiment revenir aux origines
intelligence artificielle notamment à
l'article
de 1950 d'alan turing eh bien on voit
que des sept articles de 1950 turing
parle déjà de machine learning et il
explique très bien pourquoi le match in
learning doit être deux composantes
essentielles à tout algorithme
intelligent et on reviendra d'ailleurs
longuement sur cet article de turing
dans les épisodes à venir et j'espère
que vous avez aimé cet épisode en fait
cet épisode est le premier d'une série
de cinq épisodes on va disséquer
l'article de 1950 d'alan turing parce
que cet article est juste un merveilleux
la prochaine fois en particulier on va
parler du test de turing et je vais
essayer de vous convaincre que l'idée de
ce test est absolument génial estime et
qui semble vraiment correspondre à un
test d'intelligence
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
le leak et le commentaire le partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci au
type heures pour dent et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois si on
n'arrive vraiment à créer une ia forte
son intelligence sa va pas être
l'intelligence d'un être humain
il n'y a pas de raison c'est un petit
peu comme si on imaginer si on arrive à
construire des objets qui volent
ça va voler aussi vite qu'un oiseau en
fait non c'est la conscience des objets
qu'ils veulent ce volet beaucoup
beaucoup plus vite qu'un oiseau et c'est
un petit peu la même chose avec une
intelligence sont là à créer des objets
qui vraiment sont intelligents au moins
aussi intelligent ou et ça va pas
s'arrêter là
il ya une possibilité de créer une
intelligence vraiment vraiment très
supérieure et le problème c'est que on
peut concevoir des objets qui volent
plus vite que des oiseaux s'est imaginé
mais concevoir une intelligence qui est
plus intelligente que l'intelligence
avec laquelle on essaye de la concevoir
c'est très très compliqué son sac pour
la super intelligent se pose un problème
qui est très particulier qui dira
comment faire pour penser avec notre
intelligence des êtres qui ont qui
aurait une intelligence
extraordinairement supérieur symptômes
sont des chimpanzés c'est de réfléchir
des grenouilles essaie de réfléchir à ce
que vous ferez des êtres humains